um let me ask you guys do you want to
see bullet or blitz
there's monthly bullet or daily blitz I
can't play both at the same time timing
Collier wants blitz Ilyas wants blitz
Robin Jeff's below Bishop c4 okay center
fork trick life is good
oh so many votes for blitz okay this
will be my only bullet game I'll lay
join the that's my neck e4 it's a nice
move hello hello the based scrub and
howdy to everyone else I'm down a piece
so I have to win a piece back I think
number after takes takes there's f5s
best move probably the best move a key
key move in this variation if it weren't
for a five-night b4 probably wouldn't
work
forgetting this was bullets I do have a
time advantage out of the bishop here -
and g5 incoming also the bishops gonna
get trapped there's a p3 f4 no need to
play chosen you amazing I am you Stella
go it's dreamer so flattering thinks I'm
singer okay
pausing this tournament I think everyone
wanted blitz there are no votes for
bullets Lanka bar says bullet is too
fast to follow okay what's it is join
five minutes late but in 15th place out
of 255 players
256 what do we call 256 super even or
perfect
or to to the it's to to the eighth right
what's to to the eighth
what's to to the eighth power okay
I knew it NTE ten let's play let's play
aggressively I've been doing like a
slightly impromptu series on YouTube on
super aggressive chess so I'll try and
keep it up with with this stream hello
to taggi
welcome back opponents doing some
slightly bizarre setup may be attempting
to play a hippo would like to open the
center like d5 is one way to do it it's
play d5 threatening the knight
threatening to win the pawn
if takes I'll have a choice between pawn
takes or Knight takes if you want to
play me join this tournament I'll share
a link in the chat my e5 and go on trade
and then I think I can win a pawn c6 is
not defend three ooh
invincible pawn on e6 and thanks to the
the new the new subs right eyes and it's
Nablus XL appreciate it and super manga
welcome night might be five looks
appealing
maybe f3 or maybe queen g4 queen g4 most
aggressive making a threat reinforcing
my invincible pawn 95 looks nice
yeah 95 takes takes and then the pawn is
even more than 150 Sam Vic I think so
much for the The Terminator
it's now I just have to terminate my
opponents Queen C sixes of threats if
Queen e8 I'll reposition the bishop to
c6 and then go for Queen the Queen
invasion Bishop c5 that's the move
I just want to invade hmm
takes and this is a move maybe what's
the best way to do this
good castle yeah
King safety first connecting the rooks
this bishop is pinned to the c6 square
so if takes I don't take back I just go
for meets elephant bush on a 3-month
streak now b4 yeah putting pressure on
the pinned piece
I usually don't stream with music if you
want to listen to music open a new tab
and then you can choose whatever you
want I know different people have
different tastes speaking of taste I
made some tea but I forgot to pour it
let's win a bishop let's win a bishop
with my bishop
so if takes and I made into okay nice
starts snack attack is back okay back to
tournaments
I have pumpkin spice tea don't think
there's any caffeine but it's goodness
in a cup super mingle asking how do you
suggest to play against a stronger
player and yourself I mean general
advice play the board not the player
just try and play the best moves unless
they're lower rated then you can bizarre
let's play d4 I want to play
aggressively playing a Queen's Gambit
ooh let's play this one's gambit
accepted 'if I've probably have like a
iqp position so there's there's
downsides and upside stabbing this pawn
downside is it's kind of lonely because
there's no neighboring pawns to support
it never mind
this is reasonable structure but the
bishop the bishop on f4 I mean the
upside still in this position is the
deep one controls more space it's also
the only center pawn on the board but
okay in the meantime I'm just trying to
improve queen d3 Bishop g6 is a problem
Bishop looking for tactics with Bishop
d6 and doing things
[Music]
I think I'll go for this visual d6 Queen
b3 is interesting some tension here this
bishops tied down to the pawn
so if takes I take down that seven with
check some idea of Knight g5 this
bishops not defended it's aligned with
the Queen but there's no great knight
moves maybe might have fates but I like
in retreats I also want to play this
move yeah b5 is reasonable move back to
you two would have liked to stay on this
diagonal but with Bishop e2 I defend the
night I avoid the double pawns might be
six probably coming this is gonna be a
fights
blocks playing solidly has a time
advantage that White's position looks
okay Oh what to do
maybe rook c1 some future idea of c4
okay now there's some pin action yeah
let's get off the diagonal well I want
to play Bishop d3 target h7
I also like to find a better square for
the night it's not really doing that
much it's restricted by the F pawn okay
attacking the H pawn play Queen c2
defending this okay now after g6 there's
some weakness like h6 and f6 or a bit
weaker so I think nice idea is 92 to e4
black threatening to win a pawn let's
push now actually the pawns kind of tied
down whoa what just happened
I was really weird I just did something
weird like before okay let's play Queen
d2 Oh actually wait I'm losing am I
losing material oh no there's a trap or
is there a chop dah
no I'm I would be the one getting
trapped cuz might be - that's very
devious I could take on
he ate first hmm might be - Wow
okay to deal with the consequences I'm
down upon opponents playing very well
but it's gonna be a fight I'm gonna try
and get some attack on the kingside and
I think I'm threatening to take on Ian
and then take on c4 never mind
you're still threatening this I want to
do this in this still yeah now I'm
fighting f6 and might have some juicy
squares
Roka faith Bishop each for perhaps
applying a lot of pressure trying to
calculate g5 Bishop takes g5 takes this
not quite working
95s come in I have the c5 square it's
still some tactical potential
I'm 26 seconds not that much time bring
the bishop back I should fight for the
e-file
93 we could trade nights lovely Queen oh
no that would be blunder Asst any Queen
D to be safer rookie seven ideas - okay
we trade do I have a threat here not
sure if I have a threat just bluffing
okay so I'm down to pawns but lots of
Clare bishops still some attacking
potential it's gonna be a time scramble
down three pawns but pawns don't matter
when we're both all in time Queen b8 I
want to play this and eventually mates
it's all about initiative now rook here
defends g8 with the bishop but okay I'm
threatening mate in one Bach has a
couple checks but nothing too harmful
now I'm up on time might win this this
might actually be winning for whites
like regardless of time situation not
entirely sure okay well I was a weird
game felt like I I got outplayed
something weird happened in the middle
game where it it just crashed for a
split second it's white winning like in
that position here a singing g5 and the
King has to run but looks like it should
be winning somehow plus 0.8 what
oh so rookie you want any move Oh Ricky
won Queen f7 and somehow White's better
after f3 it's really random
I have 3 attacking the rook
some like really don't know if I
understand this line f3 idea to play
this and eventually Bishop h6 a far far
far is back with a thousand bits thanks
so much a far far far okay back to the
tournament 14th place trying to stay
clean I think what I'll do is all
berserk anyone below 2000 maybe at some
point I'll do a treatment where I desert
everyone opponents over 2000 let's play
let's play chess caro-kann I've really
been liking the hillbilly attack lately
not sure if I've had the best results
with it but it's an aggressive approach
gambling a pawn will eventually play off
three because always play off three
yeah I did say at the time that came by
mating rather than flagging my opponents
'if I've was he five
I think all I'll just develop I'm
envisioning the center opening up and
black being underdeveloped for example
Bishop here and d4 maybe she not sure if
that's so great
Oh Bishop here I just went up on the
fook sia refuted the hillbilly attack
with a5 a5 but a 4
maybe can look into that explai 3
question the bishop
I wear shoes welcome back I got new
shoes other day my old shoes were
falling apart have to be more respectful
to shoes so black has a few choices at
Bishop h5 I play g4 and maybe when the
e-pawn that's interesting I could take
off 7 I mean taking off settings just
necessary it's actually a really funny
line which is not gonna happen
I was thinking after takes night here
here here the King would land on e5 and
it would be funny but ok this is this is
also kind of fun the Kings on e7 bishops
attacks I don't have to move the bishop
because I have g5 but I should probably
move the bishop it's the only
LightSquared bishop on the board which
means I'll just probably dominate the
light squares some queen a3 idea but
that's only one check this is a double
attack hmm interesting move
I mean Bishop e2 is kind of sad queen a3
doesn't need too much Queen b3 is a move
not sure
Queen d4
what's material I'm up upon so I can
afford to stock up on let's just develop
might even treat me to 100 bonus 10
mm-hmm but you disagree
thanks for the bits I appreciate that so
I have a time advantage
the queen is expected to take I might
just take the ship g5 have a nice lean
development
oh please play g5 oh I see the emotes g5
was possible I probably should have
considered it but don't worry I still
have a jeep on I can play g5 later when
things are even more developed the king
is still a bit awkward blocking the
bishop the knight is pinned to the king
if the king moves back then the rooks
don't get connected I want to play d4 I
won't open both Center files and then
eventually checkmate
the files have to open up
ceefor I just take threatening to take
expecting this
yeah Bishop c5 sacking looks dubious
let's play rook d2 just getting ready
for the double up also getting ready
maybe for this never mind
Bishop f4 there's choices here let's
play Bishop f4
not sure where the Kings gonna go if
this and this and I'll have some fun cod
Bishop e6
looks Pleasant
the problem for Locke the king is just
stuck which means the night's stuck even
if the king was to do that night still
pinned and the goal is just to apply
even more pressure
wait this is a two-hour tournament I
thought this all won our tournaments
just seeing let the time here I guess
maybe I'll play the whole tournament I
guess we'll see
so I guess I do have time to fight for
for first place let's do this
envisioning a position where okay this
is expected ah maybe I could have taken
I should have considered taking
actually I'm probably just winning a
piece here take sticks can win the rook
or at the very least I'm yeah I mean
this is this is pretty much over
as if takes I just win the rough if that
looking for my windmill
I do have a windmill emote but sadly the
windmills are no longer in existence
because there's been some changes so
approach s League more on that in the
future but the windmill in terms of
chess tactics still exists don't think
this will be like a a real windmill but
we'll see
Rick t7 looks nice where's my meat
always playoff 3 preparing this in this
thinking I should play c-4 explosive
mainly covering the square hmm again
where's my mate
let's play this training maiden one
there we go okay dr. tournaments top 10
3 wins 2 3 4 all desert I want to make
it 2 3 4 5 I have work off seven Rogoff
seven block would move the king and
defend the rook whoa it's a thousand
more bits a far far far far a far far
far far what opening do you want to see
tell me what to play okay I guess we
have a London no choice this is entice
London line b3 play Bishop hey this
that's a solid approach all the line the
rook with the Queen some idea of taking
and then might be for later
so white hasn't played h3 which means
let h5 should probably get the bishop
pair or not the bishop pair but trade
like for Bishop but maybe not at six
hear of g5 do I want to go for that
let's do it playing aggressively
my Knights defended I have that open in
each file so I probably won't castle
play this let's play this
I'm not h4 interesting let's play a five
all I could take
I could take twice it looks risky though
let's play f5 first the problem like if
I took twice I could maybe win the rook
but you six things in the end I think
there would be too much counter play so
completing development first there's
almost some tactics let's play King g7
developing my final piece more
importantly though clearing the way for
the rook I think I want to do this in g5
or GFI first and then this I think
there's gonna be problems for lights on
H file with upon ng4 and with upon ng5
um this pond is kind of stuck did I
accomplish from night a three Sicilian
you'll have to watch like the four to
five hours I played in the autumn
marathon to see if I play that but if
you want a spoiler then yes I did I did
accomplish it
and I think I won in like a really messy
game okay so time is precious whoo
there's my enough one coming so can I
take first and sack and do stuff
let's start with this
expecting 93
I really want to just go insane
take first takes takes almost works
take stakes
it's so close to working I can't resist
can resist wait do I take first really
do I take on each two first maybe that's
too insane
let's take their first oh that's why I
wanted this is nice meet these pawns for
puns connect for it but with different
colors okay
I mean 9f2 was what should have been
played and I wasn't entirely sure if
this is sound I'm fantasizing about like
Bishop takes g3 just sake more stuff and
then threatening mates hey it's more
bits oh maybe this does work cuz King f1
I just I go for meat and sacking i
sacking a knight on d4 a bishop on g3
and then the exchange I'm each one would
have been pretty sweet so it's a
swinging chair Bishop takes g3 oh it's a
draw because chess is always a draw
Queen B 5 and somehow that that's okay 4
bytes
okay back to tournaments thanks again
for the bits arf arf arf
but you want to see a London that I play
because I can always play a London maybe
if I'm lights yeah let's play a London
I'll bezerk again ooh the copy
confirmation with a copycat variation I
don't recommend playing the typical like
c3 setup I recommend playing the setup
with c-4 Queen b3 targeting the one
undefended thing in blacks position and
often block plays this after v6 were
actually going to have like a reversed
variation of what we had the last game
let's play Knight d2
again preparing Rexy one I put them out
in d2 so my rooks not so obstructed I
mean we might see the same type of thing
okay h6 so it'll be slightly different
I'll put my knight here
restricting this light from developing
because now it's tied down to a pod
hollow to a KD 707 welcome back z nation
asking question about Kotov thoughts on
kota AUVs thinking like a grand master
book you're asking the wrong person
unfortunately I have not read that book
I think I've heard of it I like the
title that I can't I can't offer any
insight there's a d6 is a move but
really no reason let's just move back so
I have the bishop here and there are
dark-squared bishop is it's a very nice
piece to have the pierces through blacks
territory
there's bishops he's seven here as you
see seven is a move Bishop e5 is a move
it's a lot of moves well start with this
should be sudden a bishop the bishop see
sudden just diving in now there should
be five I'll probably move the knight I
just want to keep invading Locke's
territory hello youtube say hi T og GI
in the comments mmm you two people
watching in the future you know what to
do
don't disappoint the one who know me tog
II black wants to fork me so I defend
and I threaten the skewer
I also clear the way for the rook
so 97 maybe this may be stillbrook c7
wait there's options Bishop b4 there's
not much time though let's play rook c7
looks fun mm-hmm I should probably move
my Knights I just want to double up
the thing is I'm not up any material but
my pieces are good
my time is not good at 41 seconds I have
to up the tempo there's some f3 move
Claire three because always playoff
three Bishop before we keep attacking
the Knights Wow
king of to wait my rook is almost
trapped okay we could trade yeah let's
trade in this move
oh we're gonna have an endgame can Trey
Queens I will trade Queens I still have
the bishop pair two bishops versus two
nights
it's play oh I wanted to play for not a
three okay let's play this move a four
No okay now a four because box pawn is
kind of weak might be a Bishop d6 push a
d6 anyway okay this is gonna be hard to
win unless it's easy to win okay I take
upon now I'm up up on King go this way I
for on a breakthrough a Bishop e7 coming
that's taking Bishop e7
yeah here's a break thrive pawns on both
flanks to connected Pass was here 11
seconds plenty of time I'm just pushing
the Jeep on safety first
I have meanin what Bishop d8 was oh
that's not me in the one I'll still play
Bishop the eights Jack okay not still me
because black has plumps Oh
took a little bit of work their opponent
played well like put up a resistance I
felt like I maybe I could have had
tactics but it was hard to break through
oh you like the mug I don't know where
the smug came from it was part of the
apartments when I moved in Belgium
novice welcome back is there an art to
crying like a Grand Master should ask
Ben Feingold not entirely sure
let's bezerk English by physics back
super aggressive chess
helping counter gambits whoa
c5 why not c5 is actually kind of
logical cuz I just want a pawn on d4 b5
maybe no but maybe III III kills my fun
what to do let's take yeah let's take
like that and then this keeping all the
tension or at least some of the tension
takes takes take with Queen the Knights
pinned I want to win a pawn if Queen a4
knight c6 this is all line actually
Queen takes b4 and we would trade Queens
okay now I have to probably take and
then a fourth ok playing aggressively
down a little bit of time oh I still
have to make it connect four emotes I I
had the actually like I started it in
Photoshop but then I got distracted and
then I forgot it's like when g5 tying
down the bishop to the the g2 pawn ok
time relatively balanced the Queen is
happy here and this move want to invade
the light squares Bishop e2 perfect
light from castling
and Queen c2 expected it's actually a
cool tactical idea if Queens he choose
played in Queen c2 III wouldn't be as
strong coming up
it's just Castle still waiting for Queen
c2 because Queen c2 III I think black
wins the piece I don't wanna repeat
maybe III hear Bishop f5
fish about five okay I want to play III
trying to be aggressive
hmm
when Bishop has kind of pinned what to
do
that's slightly uncomfortable Bishop d3
is interesting
oh wait that's splendorous let's just do
this passive but so I have an idea to
play this King h8 f5 yeah I'll submit
the bishop on you for the thing is the
bishops kind of pinned so Bishop d3
might happen
f4 looks fun but let's take first on b6
pinning the rook hmm let's make a lift
actually let's do this first
hmmm still pinning the rook also
defending my own rook okay let's take
pressuring the pinned piece okay we
trade everything it's unclear hmm like
win ce6 it's a very slow time scramble
okay making lifts
it's been a lot of dancing around this
game nice game game their rating points
third place
AHA so I'm still a little bit out of
first place yeah of course I've heard of
T Han I played T Han good number of
times he's been streaming for at least a
couple years or at least a year I think
he has a plus score against me on me
chess playing in any big US tournaments
not in the foreseeable future
actually don't know when my next
tournament will be like over the board
but my next like big match I'll be
against fiddler I think it's gonna
happen within the next 10 days
still working on scheduling things
though did I get a haircut
yes I got a haircut in Taiwan the
hairstylist didn't speak English
but I had a picture handy so I just
showed the picture and it was super easy
what to do I'm playing the Ben Feingold
opening I think Ben likes to go for this
plan eventually f5 like fiing Keller the
night kind of weird black is law in
space but it's a counterpunching opening
the two main breaks are f5 and b5
yeah I mean if if I have a plus score
against Magnus and anyone who has a plus
we're against me is better than Magnus
and as a deserving world champion I'm
drinking a pumpkin spice tea it's nice
it's calming no caffeine I'm actually
planning to stream later tonight it's
1:45 p.m. right now I'm playing the
stream at 7 p.m. for the arena Kings
tournament not sure if I'm gonna stay
awake
I'll try still very much jet-lagged but
maybe I'll I'll find some tea with with
more caffeine so with 9006 idea is to
play Knight c7 and just put all the
pieces so that they prepared b5 unless
if Y plays before then I'll just kind of
be solid link b6 and very soon I want to
play f5 if I get enough for then I can
organize some attack do this right away
don't rush em I play Queen C AIDS
just prepare it even more opponent keeps
disconnecting hmm whoa that's
interesting move
that's a scary move be very careful um I
mean we're trading trade traded yeah uh
hmm oh this is very tricky ah takes
have to be very careful here the night
the White Nights gonna come to d5 later
[Music]
there's problems on the surfaces doesn't
look too bad
I think maybe I'll take I have some idea
d6 Bishop t8i d5 Bishop do you yeah have
a feeling I'm gonna have to try and win
this game on time I want to do this in
this eventually Knights kind of Pindell
though f4 it's bits
thanks chest poems
I was a very difficult position
yeah the problem okay so that the goal
is just to make the game lasts as long
as possible
Bishop yeah I guess looks ugly but oh
there's Queen c3 in the end between c3
the Queen e6 not that bad
it's all about time there's opponents
like playing pretty flawlessly that's
very strong takes takes Oh No
oh no it's just force meets and not yet
takes
looking for some way to survive
to try this 26:26 just loses because
takes inmates notes this is just force
me what move can i play
I need Ricky move to play Queen FA
there's a threat so Bishop e7 oh no
Bishop e7 doesn't work and Bishop f6
it's unfortunate it was very unfortunate
play this
yep what to do
mmm well
oh it's nice demonstration how to to
beat this opening yeah what to do
back to tournaments okay I'm gonna try
and recover from that
but yeah I'll look at that game closer
after the treatments thanks for the sub
arm ARP and thanks for the comments
Roberts on phone and doll
Queen c7 this is a this is a trendy line
black wants to play e5 Queen c7 back
with us
efore is a the usual idea
yeah I am not aware of the fishiness
from a previous game
thankfully it doesn't happen like at
least stuff like that hasn't happened
like so frequently but yeah it's one of
the the issues these days even still
let's castle castle there let's play g4
wanna play g5 thanks for the bits a.k.a
KD 707 expecting black to Castle
queenside actually play Queenie three
I'll Castle this way
I'm just trying to recover from the
previous game
a solid position nothing special for
whites things idea like the go-to
positional idea is to just double up on
the old only open file the thing is this
might lead to two trades whoa that's a
move I could take
I might sack up on again in 95
sacking g2 it could also play g5 the
thing is I'm not really better here I do
this
94 takes and then take c6 probably not
mmm wait let's start with this
simplifying a little bit expecting rook
takes
and now maybe this
trying to put some pressure on my
opponents
there's some idea there's a D 595 and
the Queen can't doesn't have access to
any square as long as diagonal that
Queen b6 Queen here you could see a
potential windmill camera quality using
the Logitech something-something webcam
there's also a green screen which is
invisible
what you do for morning treatments I
mean most tournaments usually have a
round that starts in the morning usually
you should get yourself on a reasonable
scheduled sleep schedule where you're
waking up at least a few hours before
the round
I'm usually a night owl so it can be
difficult but ok with enough discipline
like a week before the tournament try
and get yourself on a good routine and
eat breakfast too and drink tea
we work here okay some pressure I have
to catch up 12 points one hour in one
minute to do so take whoa it's a
donation glad to catch one of your
streams I always learn a lot from your
videos thanks so much platypus I
appreciate that a little bit conflicted
here so I want to take on you six but
Queen d6 is a kind of a problem so I'll
take here if Queens a excited.i fork the
pawn in the King
if pawn takes and black has some damage
structure upon takes I probably don't
win the pawn back
let's play
- do I want to get a rope to be for
let's play this turning the pond maybe
queen bee for green before of t1
yeah I still I still have to get around
to making a a video on the two nights
attack against the French there's also
two nights attacking it's a Carol con
play that a lot in like in streams maybe
next time I give luxuries in the st.
Louis I'll have to give a full lecture
on it okay
pawns are attacked she poured what
should you let's play this move there's
so many potential weaknesses but at
least so far like box doing a good job
of defending things never been timid
thanks so much
500 bits I have a feeling I'll win this
game on time
it's mighty 4 go for the tack
oh that's not legal I thought was made
in - oh wow let's play up three because
always five three all the goal is to
meet Oh H for coming hmm
there there there rook g 7h for takes h3
take sticks she'll be okay yeah this is
all forests
hmm
oh there's cool line oh I wish that game
continued king b5 rook c1 and white wins
cuz force meets oh not force me black
wins forget you three check and in
Queens nevermind
okay cuz I won on time fourth place wait
I thought I just had 26 points oh no I
had 24 points
oh man so in order to like fight for
first I have to really deserve the rest
of my games and play even more
aggressively okay
aggressive play time we'll have a knight
c3 Sicilian let's play each for itself
online now d4
Oh should I play the Bishop g5 so usual
the usual idea this should also be okay
go for f3 some kind of Yugoslavia
you success of its change to combine
with g6 and dark Spurs are a bit weak
it's playable the ship before it could
happen play off three
I always play king b1 we might end up
trading and this could get very
positional
what's my favorite opening generally the
London but it always depends
it can change day by day so I have
double pawns but I have two bishops I
think two bishops are usually worth
damage pawn structure to do let's play
Knight h3 I think I want to organize
some attack ship d3
I think the goal is to eventually open
some file
unfortunately my pawn structure is not
not going to help with the attack
leadership c5
b6 bishop g1
hmm
I think the plan is rook rook somewhere
I think with pawn maybe now a7 is hit
I have to play the ship g1 or I could
take out seven I take out seven takes
takes there's 93 so there's some long
calculation takes takes 93 but then I
probably just take and I should be a
pond in the end how do you learn all
these opening names experience or
Wikipedia I guess I think there's a a QP
Nia page like all opening names
okay so I have three Center ponds I've
been laying on the back rink but it's
not gonna get trapped unless ooh I guess
it's not gonna get trapped it's just
being one for free
thankfully I still have my my center
ponds so this is gonna get a little bit
spicy never been timid two nights video
two nights video two nights video I need
help against the fridge
okay if you say that a few more times
maybe all I'll remember let's play let's
play this first I want to bring the King
in quickly I'll also play E for the rest
of the stream so maybe we'll have a
French pop up some eating idea to
eventually do this with the King on e5
do you play king e5 oh that's not me
though actually it probably would have
been mates let's check again
tricky position the rooks kind of stuck
on the back the bishop is also houses a
bishop escape henry lord watan oh yeah
I've been a catch a live stream woohoo
woohoo
it's been a while okay let's check again
hmm
I should probably just push pawns you
have pawns have to go marching one by
one
[Music]
okay this should be winning d6 coming
mmm still a bit tricky actually
huh
attacking the spawn I also have another
threat which I'm hoping black doesn't
see I saw I was reading this to just win
okay let's walk this up probably to e5
or to c5
yeah so I want to check but no rush
extra pollen will play a role preventing
king c6
hey I got my reading refund it's a
miracle
ooh ooh this is gonna be nice it's
taking pawn
unleashing the rook okay back to
tournaments Oh
it also refunded my to give me a winner
just canceled the game maybe I cancelled
the game wow I just cancelled the game
so that game let's just pretend it never
existed there's yeah good thing I'm not
famous no documentation no clips no
rewinding okay back Salvage okay let's
preserve again let's play aggressively
yeah I mean it was pretty obvious but
like streaming in front of a large group
I never want to accuse someone before
they're like officially banned I also
just like to stay away from drama
okay takes actually Queenie seven I
think is a move right let's take first
more bits from arf arf arf arf I cut I
keep forgetting it's not a far far far
far
it's arf arf arf arf like a dog
so Queenie too might actually win a
piece for white
Queenie to d5 takes takes after three F
3 is pretty lethal well I have an idea
to fly plays Queenie to like 22 takes
doesn't work I'll do a a sub stream very
soon I wanted to do one yesterday but I
drove back from st. Louis and when I got
back I was really tired so I'm able do
one tomorrow what did you defy it was
just for treats still have points to
catch up 12 points behind the lead but I
do have my streak let's do this
good afternoon to mr. sir I'm very manly
mane okay so I'm probably a little bit
worse nothing too bad
should develop there should be seven
play Bishop d7 oh this could be annoying
the Queen III I have 95 castling
what does it a mean on my mug I don't
know maybe it stands for I know what
words start with a you tell me
Brook VA okay open the file I could
Bishop f8 let's play d5 making the
Knights slightly less happy oh yeah it
stands for our far far far one that was
pretty obvious bishop you six maybe well
the play Bishop before the right moment
hmm okay I'm inspired by my opponents
night retreats to retreat my own knights
and to trade I think there's a saying I
can't get mated with a knight's on f8 I
mean so far this game has been like just
kind of passive not super exciting
it'll get exciting though it's gonna
come down to some time scramble or some
blunder or some tactic mmm
whites attacking by night g6
I think the goal is just to trade stuff
yeah let's trade stuff we could trade
more stuff let's start with this
they don't want to play g6 or maybe I
don't
the my night kind of get stuck
Wow takes oh wow wait what's going on
okay let's move my rook yeah I had so
many things I could have taken but
nothing worked
yeah and it's gonna come to this
annoying square
I want to bring my Knight to f5 38
seconds always playoff six I'd see five
coming
rocky eight looks reasonable whoa the
night skiing cattle in my territory but
I'm dealing with it
nights so annoying
let's do this move yeah my night defense
take and play this still a lot of kind
of defending this pawn of d3 9 F for
counter-attack ooh
forgot about that takes takes let's take
this it's gonna get sharp let's take a
pawn now I want to bring the king to f4
I also want to just promote my D pawn 13
seconds
yeah want to go for a meet 30 made in
one it's so close to meet oh let's not
do that yet
Wow that's not me either
no yes the dirty flag what nastiness so
nasty I don't think I'll win the
tournament first place is so far away
and I'm trying to stay clean but it's
hard to stay clean after that nastiness
okay whoa
it's heartwise a noodle opponent resigns
probably scared by the bits thinks hard
y'see middle not sure why the opponent
resigns there I was looking forward to
playing e4 or d4 probably for though
okay always have to stretch 41 minutes
which is the best opening against the
Sicilian
not sure should ask a sermon I think he
knows okay
this was recommended fighting for first
to play something aggressive okay we
have a whatever this is Oh a Stonewall
do I play against a stone wall g6 Bishop
f5 what hobbies do you like outside of
chess tennis ping pong bowling
photography Scrabble boggle I'm trying
to learn how to cook yeah I have other
interests I was thinking at some point
I'll start like a second youtube channel
like just content that's not chess but
we'll see okay 94 or even the second
twitch channel livestream myself cooking
what is this have six No let's not get
forked that's a threat it's a weird
position
I'm low on time - I think my king is
still kind of safe it's a little bit
shaky though mm-hmm okay I should bring
my rook end and maybe trade Queen's
Plate you six pretty sure Yasser Serra
Wong was live on the chest fraud Channel
cooking lasagna I think I caught a
glimpse of its own oh okay I'm getting
distracted opponent didn't take off
seven though but it's still a scary
position mmm tied to
oh this is terrifying I've six in King
g8 not the move I wanted to play now
have six okay feeling a bit safer lights
almost trapped it has to move here and
we trade I can trade some more you'll
play this first I've not lost a single
pawn somehow my Jeep hog migrated to the
e-file huh
okay b5 the a5 have to use my pawns as I
have a love them
g5 might happen but it might not g5
takes takes takes h4 brigades h7 should
be good for me
so we might see h4 but then rogue h7
first I think I want to play rook h7
King f7o White has not lost a single
pong either this is tricky and White's
pawn structure is very much intact play
rook g7 maybe wait like can't defend g4
and winning upon those g5 I'll take
everything let's take with ya let's
trade all the rooks let's take again
yeah let's just write everything this
should be winning might see this move
but all of whites pawns are fixed on
dark squares which means what does it
mean
not sure what it means okay let's invade
I'm gonna attack III
pay for a fort was not necessary at all
I'm thinking if we trade bishops it
should be winning 26 seconds
yeah Bishop's just come off laborious
winning how to force a trade to bring my
bishop like this and this and then bring
the King to f3
my problem is White's gonna wait
oh I mess up
here here oh do I have some magical
breakthrough I might have a magical
breakthrough this is very tricky though
here I breakthrough yeah let's do it
I think it works and then here I'm
sacking all the pawns look at this I've
just sacked three pawns to break through
Oh
if ticks I would have played a three
okay plenty of time
okay well the game I was a nice break
through I'm not sure if it was winning
maybe you have to go back and check
pretty sure it was drawn at some point
over again like before the bishops got
traded and I think those drum oh let's
play my day three Sicilian because why
not
Knights on c4 Queen on c7 F for no let's
do this
blacks trying to play a time on uh-huh
play c3 putting the pot I like free
pawns okay I have nine points to make up
I'm getting closer
I think the plan is to like slowly
prepare D for mmm tricky move like
weenie well no that's a bad move
the threat is this what to do those
night c4 back
yeah 32 minutes left I have to try and
stay focused
I think the goal is to eventually attack
like move the night play f/4g 4h for
pawn storm eventually checkmate
what is this develop so all the minor
pieces developed yeah I want that to
play d4 but oh wait what I have a free
queen and then I just dropped a bishop
oh I trusted my opponents was that
trying to stay focused
I clearly lost focus there no need to
get tilted I'm only down a piece queen
is maybe trap level I want to play g3f
for the fee this is a fatigue of thing
so much chess like just missing the
easiest things I could have finished
this game by now
let's play this first and you want to
play g3
whoa g3 doesn't quite chop the Queen
also my Knights kind of stuck now this
is looking really passive mmm Bishop b3
actually maybe Bishop here just tying
this light down to this night and this
lights kind of pinned just have to
create some pressure against black it's
a good move play this
no not of three
I'm hanging more stuff please don't take
it please don't take it actually Aflac
takes it it's still interesting
okay the bishop was just hanging but I
would have Knight g5 so it could have
been interesting Oh
- do we have to trade Queens okay this
is a very low quality game so far but
let's try and try and make it even more
low quality by winning it oh dear
I'm not gonna win it with the way I'm
playing
I have to be optimistic oh dear
d4 play d4
hmm
okay I'm down a minute on the clock it
could be worse
hmm play c5 or just win a pawn with
check finally something good happening
except it's still looking really bad
let's take that
okay it still takes work for luck to win
I'll play g4
okay this might be a draw actually
unless I want to play for a win I'm
playing for a win I don't know why I'm
doing this I'm playing for a win
I'm sorry to my opponent opponent played
very well but that's the nature of blitz
and no increment and dirty flagging okay
I don't deserve this streak to keep his
irking I could have drawn by going into
that rook ending probably but it's all
about fighting for first before time
Center for trick
just try and play aggressively maybe win
g7o tricky move Wow
Queen up to is safest which war is a
good move because g3 came out of Three
Forks
Sean ferry thanks for subbing gifted by
sad Bishop I think sad Bishop I'm gonna
try and make my bishops happy I have one
happy bishop
- happy bishops Black has one side
Bishop one place c5 open the file or a
five even
if black takes twice I win a piece oh no
I'm losing okay there is Bishop g4 just
winning the exchange but now I'm winning
a piece the longer this tournament goes
the lower the quality just integrates I
have a windmill dr mate
this is good enough its wins both rooks
okay back two tournaments 53 points on a
streak
yeah Sean ferry you have access to two
emotes now let's reverse again let's do
this through the past gambit time my
first Budapest of the stream a far far
he's drifting streaking legally castling
or coming five typical
hitting the bishop and the pawn
expecting Bishop e2
oh good take up on or I can lift
let's lift
I just want to do this
draw some arrows enjoy light could take
this first hmm she was very close to
winning with Queen g5h for
trying to calculate like forcing moves
I think there's a nice line to play oh
wait it doesn't quite work let's do this
first
I'm allowing this but don't think I care
about the c-7 pawn yeah and I was
thinking this or wait no just this even
simpler
this is meeting yeah this is the power
of the Budapest like this middle game
rook lifts if white doesn't deal with it
properly and get very bad
you might should've played Bishop e2 all
a lot of these double pawns
ok tied for first both one of us have 50
eights
playing Canada master let's preserve it
why not do you even lift though I lifted
earlier today had my Orangetheory
workouts let's play this playing a
reverse Grand Prix efore so the point is
playing a it's known as a box system I
can't complain with this
I'll have my typical grand-prix
attacking ideas
hmm maybe f4 first now let's do this
first
wanna play I foreign when the pawn if
King age - maybe this so playing
aggressively
why would like to trade Queens but the
knight doesn't have any squares that's a
move
probably very logical move could play f4
it could get weird shortly like if it
takes maybe after three after three the
problem is this other than takes and
stuff happens
interesting so I can take here
hmm not sure if I'm getting so much out
of this
on IG three we trade everything I save
the bishop it's possible
I'm curious what my opponent will do
here
because there is some scary pressure
from multiple directions
thinking that g4 is some resource just
taking and meaning on h2
like maybe starting with no it doesn't
quite work I do this so no night g3 yeah
let's just take
yeah this could actually turn positional
pretty quickly
or I could keep it tactical like Knight
g3 I could either trader play Queen h4
leaning towards Queen h4 because I want
to play Knight g4 and I want to keep the
tack I could take my chief or f4 take
stakes here here inmates oh no that's
not me but it looks fun
okay just a party on the kingside
some weird line Bishop g5 ticks ticks 93
it might happen but 93 Queen d2 is a
problem so let's play 94 first pawns are
equal oh wait I just hung a piece for
nothing I forgot that was attacks oh
that's kind of sad quality chests down
on time too playing good player this is
gonna be hard to come back from but I'll
try
and guys come back from worse positions
play this first the first step is to not
panic to take a deep breath
and then to freak out
i-22 every wonder deserves a sub every
blunder deserves a question mark but
thanks for the sub must eq to do
probably this just trying to confuse my
opponents
yeah this is probably very problematic
take here
eg six
yes I'm not getting needed yet I have a
queen not sure how much work my queen
can do
I'm not sure what to expect from lights
it's hard to calculate okay so what is
this material situation that's a good
move
oh dear what is going on here lease I
have pawns
a lot of plants Wow am i winning I might
be winning this yes
am i winning this it's a miracle
Wow Mikey somehow I won Matt I just
wound up with like so many pawns there
was a queen versus two rooks and two
minors okay 6363 oh I meant to play e4
but I guess I'll play a London to
unleash some London prep okay yeah
usually ninety-seven is now um best whoa
a far far far 5,000 bits the
tournament's not over but thanks for the
motivation the slight distraction okay
well thank you so much xxx mates Oh what
to do
let's move the Queen back and just
pushing each pawn or keep the bishop
here okay free pawn this is already
looking quite nice don't want to trade
Queens play a sneaky move I could have
taken but I didn't want to lose my
bishop
and I can take looks nice
how kim taek's okay this looks very nice
rook t1 probably next to get my bishop
to this diagonal I could play Knight of
6 or that wins the Queen takes I take
the Queen
okay life is good just have to win this
quickly and get in a couple more games
okay hey first place this is the first
time I'm in first place as tournament
and number two lost the streak it looks
like okay a thousand bits from
Terminator 1000 bonus 100 thank you so
much okay gonna try and stay focused and
keep as irking and play aggressively and
play g4 not too often you can play g4 on
move to is black okay let's just kick
the night around like it's a soccer ball
that's 9 on d3 I could take let's play
h5 just gonna keep pushing pawns so far
it's working out more bits bits I think
so much a far far far far
let's just keep pushing pawns the first
eight moves are pawn moves c4 no time
for a bishop move turning upon you pawns
pinned to the rook and I'll continue to
push pops first 11 moves I've only owned
one piece okay time to move more pieces
[Music]
this is interesting wanna play knight c6
actually this looks fun d5 if d3 I'm
just gonna leave the bishop okay I
forgot about that
well that's okay this is a weird
position I want to win Kinect for my
only chance not gonna happen so I'm only
down upon I try and hit the Queen
what's the best approach not sure what
my plan is it's such a weird position if
Queen here it would threaten mate in one
you work before suck another pawn
how to punish the opponent
not sure if my opponent deserves
punishments I mean all white is doing is
taking free pawns
that's fianchetto and castle actually
let's fight you six first it takes and I
that's a move
let's do this very weird line could
happen Bishop here takes takes takes I
have triple pawns on the D file with a
neighboring pawn
what is this position this is very close
to quadruple plots ok the Knights doing
things I could take this pawn over then
this pawn hangs so maybe e5 I have
little time left
it's like e5 first feel like I'm getting
carried away all those positions
actually just really bad castling while
with a move oh let's play like this
it's clumsy 7 15 seconds
this is not gonna be good I still have
hope a little bit of hope a crazy
position to do this
most ridiculous position I've had this
tournament I'm just pushing another pawn
I don't want to promote too soon I have
nine seconds left what is happening
three nights yes okay White's stuck
which is a good thing works are
completely suck just have to find the
winning plan this is a winning plan
lucky well the games I wasn't nasty
Hulme those pawns the board okay let's
buzz Erick oh the first place person
maybe I shouldn't beserk okay um this is
a fitting finish I'll tell you for
Alekhine when I play against a Alekhine
it's play main line I'll play the setup
with b3 whoa tog II terminated 1,000
bonus 100 boo Eric thanks so much huggy
and a fo e thank you so much wait it's
my move I was waiting for Black team
button see you later 1000 bonus 100 to
play b4 before the thread is this slide
bishop c3
before finding B 5 C 6 e 5 while oh this
looks interesting
the Knights not defended okay we're
trading a lot I'm holding on to
everything I think if Knight takes I
take in Queen d4 wins the night that's a
move let's play eight for if a six I
probably take Knight c3
yeah the pawn on c5 is nice supported
it's a passed pawn that's taken this and
then rook did this rook to see one other
up to d1 I'll make loose for the King
soon
I could win d5 maybe we really could win
d5 but if to point this move that is
true also the tournament might end
before this game ends there's two
minutes left in the tournament but okay
I'm gonna try and finish with with a win
I like the position yeah I think this is
a blunder because this let's play rook
d2 I want to get this Knight here takes
a while though but let's start the
journey rookie for Queen d3 I forgot
about this pawn
okay well if rook takes a four I take
the Queen Bishop takes a four I fork
looks reasonable yeah if takes takes
takes ninety-four tax a bishop in the
pawn some see six ideas now I'll take
the pawn threatening the the triple fork
hmm say this move I'm kind of leaving
the pawn stranded let's take if this I
think I'm is that winning or maybe black
just wins the pawn okay take the pawn a
nice gift
ooh let's fork I'm winning anything
Chuck this is a winning endgame Oh No
maybe not oh let's just take the pawn
okay this should be a winning endgame
Oh tricky oh wait this is very tricky
tics
to move this way I'm inside the box
catching the pawn I think this is gonna
be a draw yeah
Oh tricky move please take up on yes but
it's still a draw
am I losing might be losing oh no wait I
won I won because I have a knight and a
knight could theoretically
checkmates if he under promotes and then
corners himself I'm so sorry it's my
fault
it's in my opponents there should have
been a draw other other sites declare
this a draw but well doctor tournament
tournaments over so that games any
confident literally five thousand more
bits I'm a far far far far thanks so
much
so I had one loss in that tournaments
that will never speak of have to destroy
the evidence
and Henry Lord baton Terminator 1000
Terminator 1000 gone is 200 thank you so
much performance rating 2390 yeah that's
doesn't sound fair maybe I factored in
the loss that will never speak of is
this YouTube worthy probably yeah for
the people watching on YouTube Congrats
thanks for watching smash the like
button leave a comment
say hello to togi in the comments and
say hello to a far far far far and night
be free and diamond cutter and everyone
else in the twitch chat